[Music]
galileo galilei was the greatest
astronomer of all time his discoveries
in the 16th and 17th centuries shocked
the establishment including the catholic
church which at the time believed the
earth was the center of the universe
armed with his telescope and a brilliant
mind galileo proved them wrong the earth
actually revolves around the sun
and for this assertion he would be
condemned to a tragic life
a century before a polish scientist
named nicholas copernicus had come up
with the unorthodox idea that the sun
was at the center of the solar system
not the earth called the heliocentric
model copernicus's theory was just that
a theory galileo proved copernicus was
right he challenged many preconceived
notions through a rigorous process of
testing
his reliance on scientific
experimentations may have started with a
fascination with pendulums as a student
he was struck by the steadiness of a
swinging lamp in the cathedral of pisa
he noticed that it didn't matter how far
the chandelier swung it always took the
same amount of time to complete one
swing galileo used his own pulse to
measure time as there were no
wristwatches back then his experiments
with pendulums confirmed that it took
exactly the same time for a pendulum to
go back and forth no matter the distance
it swung his discovery led to the later
invention of the pendulum clock which
some say opened the door for the
industrial revolution as the development
of time keeping allowed for a faster
pace of life galileo's discoveries
brought him some fame he gained a
teaching position at the university of
pisa the same university where he
dropped out a few years earlier his
father insisted he studied medicine
though he was more interested in math
and never graduated while teaching at
the university academics argued over
aristotle's belief that heavier objects
fell faster than lighter ones most
scientists agreed with the ancient
philosopher galileo did not he
reportedly set up a demonstration at the
leaning tower of pisa to prove aristotle
and his colleagues wrong if a heavier
object falls faster than a lighter one
as aristotle maintained it would look
something like this but galileo showed
that all objects regardless of their
mass freefall with the same acceleration
he was right but his smugness did not
win him many friends his colleagues felt
he got a kick out of proving them wrong
galileo's contract with the university
of pisa was not renewed fortunately he
found another teaching position at the
university of padua he needed the work
as his father had died and he was
entrusted with the care of his younger
brother michelangelo galilei who became
a composer during his nearly two decade
tenure at the university of padua his
fame increased in 1600 he met marina
gamba a venetian woman with whom he had
three children out of wedlock a son and
two daughters worried that his daughters
wouldn't marry well he urged them to
become nuns in a convent near florence
despite the fact that he had run into
trouble with the catholic church
galileo had challenged the church's
official position that the earth was the
center of the universe it all began in
1609 when he learned of a simple
telescope built by dutch spectacle maker
it was a mysterious invention that could
make distant objects appear closer
he soon built telescopes of his own some
venetian merchants saw their value as a
navigational tool and were eager to get
their hands on them while they did
eventually find their way to the decks
of sailing ships galileo's ambitions
extended beyond the seas to the skies
he used his telescope to make startling
discoveries he found that the moon was
not a perfect sphere as aristotle
believed all heavenly bodies were but
instead was full of imperfections these
are galileo's own sketches showing the
moon's valleys deep chasms and mountains
he discovered four moons orbiting
jupiter the largest planet in our solar
system destroying the notion that the
heavens revolved around earth his belief
that the earth wasn't at the center of
the solar system was solidified when he
discovered that venus went through
phases just like our moon the nature of
these phases could only be explained by
venus going around the sun rather than
the earth he concluded that venus must
travel around the sun at times passing
behind and beyond it therefore earth was
not the center of the universe the sun
was this angered the powerful people in
academia and the church the majority of
scientists and theologians agreed with
aristotle's point of view that the sun
other planets and stars revolved around
earth galileo believed in god and was in
awe of the role that science played in
the beauty of god's creation he wrote a
letter to a student explaining that his
observations did not contradict the
bible because scripture was written from
an earthly perspective but it
nevertheless got him into trouble with
the roman catholic church which at the
time essentially ruled italy in 1633 he
faced an inquisition whose purpose was
to prosecute those considered enemies of
the state he was interrogated and
threatened with torture he was then
charged with being quote vehemently
suspect of heresy and agreed to plead
guilty and was forced to recant a
scientific discovery in exchange for a
lighter sentence
his punishment was house arrest for the
rest of his life authorities banned his
book championing his belief in a
sun-centered universe and he had to stop
teaching or otherwise spreading his
quote heresy
galileo spent nine years under house
arrest at his villa in arsitry near
florence before dying on january 8 1642
at the age of 77.
it took more than 350 years for the
vatican to formally acknowledge its
mistake in 1992 pope john paul ii
apologized and officially declared that
galileo was right
galileo's work influenced scientists for
generations to come including sir isaac
newton who developed the law of gravity
i did a story about newton which i'll
link in my description
today astronomers refer to jupiter's
four moons as the galilean satellites in
honor of him in the centuries that
followed galileo's telescopic
observations telescopes have grown in
size and power revealing secrets of the
universe that even he could never have
imagined
if you're passionate about space my
friends at curiositystream have a wealth
of incredible space documentaries
including one on the james webb
telescope the world's largest most
advanced and most expensive telescope
ever their space documentaries will
enlighten entertain and inspire you to
perhaps one day travel beyond our planet
there are thousands of entertaining
documentaries my favorite is the
redesign my brain series on training
your brain to improve your attention
memory and thinking speed you can sign
up for curiosity stream for only 14.99
for the entire year with my custom link
not month by year just head to
curiositystream.com
newsthink which i'll link in my
description and pin comment thanks for
watching for newsthink i'm cindy palm